ils ont la pierre dans la peau une
vingtaine de bénévoles travaille à
reconstruire une centaine de mètres de
murs en pierres sèches une technique
ancestrale qui ne s'improvise pas sur
l'ensemble des pierres de parement il
faut les orienter vers le centre du mur
c'est à dire de leur donner du fruit
elles doivent être inclinées vers
l'intérieur du mur voilà le secret de la
stabilité le mur pourra ainsi rester
debout plusieurs centaines d'années si
l'activité demande patience et agilité
elle convient au plus grand nombre
chacun a le loisir soit d'empiler les
pierres soient de condé soit chercher
les cailloux soit 2 de déterrer d'autres
cailloux on peut trouver son compte
selon son humeur ou son sa santé ce type
de mur connu son apogée au xvième siècle
alors que le bois manquer les clôtures
furent construites en pierre
cela permettait des pierres et des
chants et de faciliter la culture
propriétaire de cette parcelle cet
agriculteur a souhaité reconstruire son
mur une démarche aujourd'hui à
contre-courant d'un peut aussi susciter
des vocations pour celui qui veut
refaire quoi comme quoi c'est possible
c'est pas quelque chose d'impossible
quelque chose d'insurmontable
avec le temps un peu de bonne volonté
ben voilà on fait on fait des belles
choses dans le paysage du haut doubs les
murs sont une trame grise est
essentielle pour l'équilibré de notre
écosystème
leur disparition menace directement la
flore et la faune comme l'hermine c'est
le moyen pour les animaux sauvages de se
déplacer s'ils ont une grande surface
devant eux
vierge de toute aide tout mur il ne
traverseront pas donc c'est un endroit
où il y en aura pas depuis quatre ans
l'association murray murger redonne vie
à ce patrimoine si ce chantier école
touche à sa fin il y encore fort à faire
pour sauvegarder les murs des campagnes
comtoise